I think this is the true genius of Ryan
Johnson here because you can't really
critique this movie without spoiling the
movie so the things that fell flat for
me have to do with you know big reveals
and the point of the movie which I'm not
gonna spoil here this isn't gonna be a
spoiler video whatever let's just talk
about knives out
[Music]
so knives out is a murder mystery
whodunit kind of written and directed by
Rian Johnson Rian Johnson you know the
name made a name for himself with the
last gen I'd love it or hate it this is
there's bits of talk on the internet but
for my money he directed looper and I
like looper a lot and it knives out the
rich leader of this family Empire
Christopher Plummer he dies deemed a
suicide within Daniel Craig he's a
private investigator and he's like I
suspect foul play
his voice is kind of strange getting
used to in the movie but you do lean
into it and you're like no actually it's
not bad it's just weird
it's a weird voice to hear coming out of
Daniel Craig more or less the star of
the show is you know I'm terrible with
names and actually here's a little
secret of mine but I don't know how to
pronounce someone's name I look for an
interview with them and usually the
interviewer will say the name right in
front of them and so you can take with
confidence so that's how you pronounce
it can't find it for her so here we go
on a day our mas she was hoping anyhow
she's a star of the show I actually
thought she was really good in the movie
like the best one in the movie
everyone's talking about Daniel Craig I
thought she was the best just the movie
required more from her than it did from
a lot of other people more range of
emotions she completely nailed it now
what I liked about this movie is the
common denominator among Rian Johnson
films I'll have this thing in Commodore
these things in common they look great
they're shot well they're well acted
also a thing Rian Johnson movies have in
common I don't think they're quite as
clever as Rian Johnson thinks they are I
said it there in the end after the shock
of this movie giving you a pretty big
puzzle piece early on in the movie I
white word alright well let's do this if
you just kind of slip into it let it
happen I was enjoying the ride until at
a point I was just kind of over the ride
it's like the first two acts of this
movie I enjoy a lot more than the last
act of the movie because the first two
acts were genuinely a new take I
wouldn't call it a whodunit it's a
different thing as a different kind of
movie the movies like oh another turn
and another terms like and this car
turns left four times so where it's like
oh now you're back on track with just a
basic plot again so it just it kind of
feels like an illusion where I'm
supposed to process it differently
because it was executed slightly
differently but in the end it's the same
trick and I thought a big part of the
last act mystery was kind of obvious
only obvious because of how Rian Johnson
herds you down this path but it's
like the movies going right no peeking
but what do I got behind my back a
tripod cuz ya kind of see that a mile
away I'm not gonna say anymore cuz it's
getting spoiler territory at that point
enjoyed the first two acts the last act
felt sloppy I've seen this a lot in
movies a sloppy third act kind of just
that's the taste the movie leaves in
your mouth and it left me with the
feeling of a good time if I were drunk
ya know it's a party to fully enjoy a
whodunit you got to dull the senses I
guess I feel like I'm supposed to love
this movie and really I walked out of
knives outgoing it's okay alright so
knives out have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to say
more
[Music]